[Music]
my name is Ken Lee and I'm a CEO or a
gpb's Hipps is a unified managed health
Cowan as we provide a base in Singapore
we offer business voice and mobile
services manage Internet connectivity
and cloud services and solutions to our
customers to be able to deliver
uninterrupted services to our customers
we look at delivering three specific
requirements being able to scale and
extend customer operations to oversee
locations assisting individual customer
portfolio requirements including
security of data and operations
delivering expertise s and when customer
requirements comes in a gpb's has been
using IBS bare-metal and virtual servers
since 2012 our partnership has really
helped us provide high-grade services to
our clientele we have leveraged IBM's
global data center coverage to extend
customer operations including converting
on-premise deployments to vsi or virtual
server infrastructure for example we
have been able to act provide voice
services for customers looking at
extending operations to either Europe
u.s. Australia being able to leverage
monetary and security capability down to
the microchip level enabling us to offer
the highest possible degree of service
to our customers
Intel txt and the latest IBM cloud hyper
protect services are good examples of
this
since IBM's bare-metal servers can be
custom configured to exact
specifications and command a monthly
consumption basis we are able to scale
up or down based on our customers
requirements lastly with IBM we have
received the highest level of service
support including implementation support
and access to expertise q set to help us
scale and grow up operations as they
repeat these growth we are constantly
exploring how to further enhance our
customers experience and offer to them a
wider range of services our partnership
with IBM assist in helping us to meet
our goals and we are looking forward to
extending this partnership to further
enhance our portfolio
you
[Music]